hey guys Greg here hello let's be crazy
to be crazy is that I called upon her
because she plays games I mean for
example you can catch her live streams
on Twitch Monday through Friday at 4
p.m. and live stream twitch chat err
dating 8 p.m. this Saturday I'm actually
gonna be on it I'm gonna be playing The
Last of Us with her
I've never played the game I know they
played some of it much maybe try to
catch up I care enough we used to play
this on my gaming channel then I went on
a Hey
went on a hiatus and then Obie brought
it back last Saturday and it was last
Saturday in the afternoon after we
already decided to stream it that day
that we found out that the Last of Us 2
of the thing so I'm like oh my god
that's perfect
because I'm so excited to finally get
back into the game and as soon as I get
back into the game there's gonna be a
new game and I'm like ah that sounds
awesome this is a great game I believe
in jibt game I believe you cuz I'm just
as much in the gaming as everyone wants
me to be child's not a gaming channel
but she's here cuz all you guys
requested last of us parts here reveal
trailer
all right enough build up let's do this
I'm not gonna understand a thing let's
go
Oh looks gorgeous I agree I totally
agree
looks like something I like to smoke
okay Wolverine was here oh man
apocalypses
yeah I'm so proud of Naughty Dog they're
bringing everything back Crash Bandicoot
[Music]
whoa is this motion capture like do they
have real actors do this yeah and they
like honestly I'm not sure but oh man
guitar
[Music]
[Music]
this is signature song I love the music
all the music is very smooth oh man they
comfort me
[Music]
cuz I know I'll kill my enemies when
they come dance a bad ass song oh
they're like a cannibalistic like zombie
type of people right but no exam leg in
this world of zombies of sugar okay yes
there are zombies the thing about this
game though is zombies are traditionally
dead however in this game the zombies
are actually not yet they're all just
affected yeah they're affected they're
like cannibals I mean because don't you
want you yeah
[Music]
just as excited as the rest of the crap
she's so grown-up
[Music]
what are you doing kiddo
[Music]
you were the gun go through this
I'm gonna find and I'm gonna kill every
one
whoa she's beautiful oh I love a girl
like that yeah yeah she really really is
gorgeous she really is she's not like
under age of this right
I don't she doesn't look a lot better
range really apply in this kind of world
oh my goodness
Wow thank you naughty dog thank you
was that guy Joel Joel I got the name
right well that's what happens when you
Wikipedia information when you're high
all right you remember a couple names
you remember a couple facts is you don't
want to seem too stupid but then you
realize it's just gonna sound like I'm
reading off Wikipedia if I share a basic
knowledge I out of the game they're on a
mission and okay yeah I have not
finished the game yet apparently we're
really close to being done with it so I
appreciate that the trailer left the
plot big it is very vague for those
people who have not played the game yet
we'll play it want to play it it doesn't
spoil anything which is perfect I think
I got some commentary I can make and I
see anyone who doesn't know gaming will
say this right away there's some amazing
graphics yes that is true though yes yes
I think what's clever about this trick
is from my understanding from people who
have talked to me about why I should
play The Last of Us the world and tone
of it and the style is a big part of
what makes you so invested in it the
more than just gameplay alone talk about
the style and I feel like the trailers
communicating the tone and the style it
is all still gonna be there and it's
gonna amplify the story which which is I
think is a great part of the game to a
lot of people that you're invested in
the story it's true it's very gritty but
at the same time is also very beautiful
which is something that I love in games
because it's very often that you have
games that are just one thing it's very
action heavy it's very horror heavy but
this is a really good mix of I think a
lot of different parts of genres that
make the game so good Ellie is all grown
up and how old is she in the first game
I believe she's 14 in the first game
okay so she's got to be like why like 18
here at least I mean okay to say she's
hot this has to be at least a cub
of years later she looks very different
okay it's like if I were to show you a
picture of Elly in the first one you'd
be like oh yeah that's little Elly
this is not little Elly what does she
mean by she's gonna kill everyone I
don't know that's why I was like this is
big so I don't know if she means more
enemies I don't know if she means the
fireflies I think she's shy it's my
enemies but fireflies like those bugs
kind of yes gotcha adopted you know
they're they're little playing no no um
fireplaces basically uh I read about
them on Wikipedia I just totally forgot
everything about it this is why I
recalled the rejects anyway I hope she
needs the fireflies because like I said
I haven't finished the first one so that
would be a great plot twist for me
gotcha
well that sounds awesome that sounds
really cool it really does it's so
exciting so happy
part of this video right that's why
you're here she's you the part that
people want me to do the excited part go
it's very well I'm going to I just don't
ever really find like I'm not just that
into gaming so and it just it's people
keep asking me to like you got to watch
this and I'm like it's a great cinematic
trailer like the song is dope sorry I
talked over a little bit I just want to
get some [ __ ] information but that
song was really cool and I love the tone
and the style and it's like a cool tease
to this it's just weird how people just
keep wanting me to like watch these game
trailers and their office they are
awesome but it's not going to lead to be
like means heavily invested again here's
the thing though is because you haven't
like played the games so Saturday when
you play it okay I gotta get it and
you're gonna be like yes freaking all
about this maybe me I guess you got a
tune in on Saturday 8:00 p.m. at which
Alyssa be crazy if you find out am I
gonna be into this game you guys got to
go find out gonna be into this game who
knows all the zombie Alyssa we're doing
a promotion right come follow me
subscriber the real rejects hit that
subscribe button
yeah and Alyssa I'm sure you gaming
people Runa so wanna check out this
twitch ELISA be crazy and she does like
a [ __ ] livestream you gotta get drunk
again if I sleep over can we get can we
get drunk oh yeah
okay I'm sleeping over I mean Runk with
you guys oh my god I found the
championship freaking I go home